qui sont pas à l'heure nous rejoindrons
commencer tout d'abord en souhaitant la
bienvenue à Coralie le Bescond qui nous
rejoint pour renforcer l'équipe de la
délégation qui vient de la commission
des affaires économiques donc rien de ce
qui se fait ici ne vous est étrangers et
vous allez aller plus profond auprès du
monde de l'entreprise
alors on est réunis pour la première
table ronde consacrée à la mission sur
la formation les compétences et
l'attractivité pour laquelle Martin
Berthet Florence blatrix compta et
Michel canevêque qui va nous rejoindre
ont été désignés rapporteur les travaux
qu'ils ont accepté de conduire
s'inscrivent dans la continuité des
initiatives du Sénat en la matière en
particulier de notre délégation qui dès
2019 c'est en paraître ce sujet ainsi
dans le rapport intitulé des compétences
de toute urgence pour l'emploi les
entreprises de nos collègues Michel
caneve déjà
et Guy Dominique kennel figurait 24
propositions visant des objectifs tels
que la suppression du cloisonnement
entre le monde de l'éducation nationale
et le monde de l'entreprise l'adaptation
plus rapide des compétences aux besoins
des entreprises avec la mise en œuvre de
plan de reconversion et des procédures
de certification accéléré ou encore la
bonne coordination des acteurs publics
de l'emploi via un pilotage des régions
de même le rapport du 8 juillet 2021 de
nos collègues Martine Berthet de nouveau
Michel caneve Fabien gay
à l'évolution c'est pas dangereux tout
ça
relatif à l'évolution des modes de
travail et aux nouveaux défis
managériaux analyser l'impact de la
récente crise sanitaire sur la relation
de travail et l'attractivité du monde de
l'entreprise la mission qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui vise à faire le point sur
ces travaux passés mais surtout
analyser les raisons de l'amplification
récente du phénomène que certains
journalistes qualifient désormais de
cauchemars numéro 1 des entreprises je
parlais des difficultés de recrutement
les raisons souvent entendues sur le
terrain sont multiples allant des
formations adaptées à l'inadéquation
géographique entre compétences et
besoins des entreprises en passant par
les nouvelles attentes des actifs à la
recherche de sens les équilibres entre
vie professionnelle et vie personnelle
et bien-être au travail l'inflexion
depuis nos derniers travaux est-elle que
l'on parle désormais de grandes
démissions
pour dresser un premier état des lieux
nous avons plaisir d'entendre
aujourd'hui
Gilbert 7 professeur d'économie à Neoma
Business School
monsieur Dimitri maverydice économiste
de la direction de l'emploi du travail
des affaires sociales de l'OCDE à
division des compétences et de
l'employabilité
monsieur vous avez récemment publié des
études sur les difficultés de
recrutement
Monsieur Michel orange
statisticien chef de la mission
d'analyse économique et la direction de
l'animation de la recherche des études
et des statistiques apparaissent je
tendron notamment sur le thème de la
grande démission au cœur d'une récente
publication de la d'Arès et enfin Madame
Coralie Perez économiste ingénieur de
recherche au Centre d'économie de la
Sorbonne vous êtes notamment co-auteur
d'un ouvrage intitulé redonné du sens au
travail
vous avez reçu les uns des autres un
questionnaire qui vous donne une
première idée de la nature de nos
interrogations pas exhaustif évidemment
et auquel nous vous demanderons de
répondre ultérieurement sous forme de
contribution écrites je vous propose
pour ce matin de dresser un premier
diagnostic en vous appuyant sur vos
travaux pour nous dire quels sont de
votre point de vue les éléments les plus
importants à retenir
disposerait 7 minutes chacun pour un
premier tour de table
et je vais ensuite la parole aux
rapporteur puis aux autres membres de la
délégation présente pour poser question
évidemment étant entendu que nous devons
conclure à 9h55 en effet une seconde
table ronde consacrée à la
simplification
autre débat débutera à 10h aussi je
demanderai à chacun d'être synthétique
mais ça vous avez l'habitude et je
rappelle que c'est au lycée surtout à
mes collègues que je dis ça
et voilà Michel canelette
je rappelle que cette audition sera
diffusée en direct sur notre site
Internet puis disponible en vidéo à la
demande je vous remercie et celle de la
parole par ordre alphabétique à Monsieur
Gilbert 7 professeur d'économie Neoma
Business School et puis on enchaînera à
la suite
ce professeur je vous donne la parole
merci bon bonjour à tous et merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président je vais
essayer d'être assez assez bref sur ces
questions là pour répondre ensuite aux
questions alors quelques points de
constat on observe je vous apprends rien
une augmentation des difficultés de
recrutement bien avant la crise de la
covid la crise sanitaire et par exemple
en France dès 2015
avec au moment de l'amorçage d'une
baisse du taux de chômage en observe
bien la montée de ces difficultés de
recrutement il y a une pause dans ces
difficultés de recrutement ensuite
durant la crise sanitaire et ces
difficultés de recrutement
de cette façon forte à partir de l'année
2021 et elles sont maintenant très très
élevées on les observe dans les trois
grands secteurs d'activités que son
industrie les services marchands la
construction et toutes les sources
statistiques disponibles
confirme ce phénomène à la fois les
difficultés de recrutement mesurées par
les enquêtes de la commission qui sont
pratiqués en France par par l'INSEE et
puis d'autres sources une enquête par
exemple de la Banque de France sur les
difficultés de recrutement puis d'autres
indicateurs du même type comme par
exemple le taux d'emploi vacants donc il
y a une convergence sur sur ce plan du
du constat ces difficultés de
recrutement c'est un deuxième point
s'observe dans tous les grands pays
européens très très fortement dans des
pays comme l'Allemagne et les Pays-Bas
ou le taux de chômage est très faible
beaucoup moins fortement dans des pays
comme l'Italie et l'Espagne ou le taux
de chômage
et fort on peut s'étonner par contre
quand on constate quand on compare les
différents grands pays européens
de la situation française ou malgré un
taux de chômage qui reste un taux de
chômage élevé en France c'est pour cent
et bien on a des difficultés de
recrutement qui sont certes moins élevés
qu'en Allemagne au Pays-Bas mais qui
sont quand même fortes et donc ce cette
conjonction de cette rencontre entre de
un fort taux de chômage et des
difficultés de recrutement élevés peut
être le symptôme d'un mauvais
fonctionnement en France du marché du
travail alors quand on regarde de près
je serai pas long là-dessus parce que
l'adresse est comme il représentant ici
de la DARES il est plus légitime que moi
pour en parler mais quand on regarde
quel type de poste sont concernés par
ces difficultés de recrutement on va
être que d'une part ça concerne des
postes qualifiés et là ça ça peut
révéler des problèmes de formation et
puis ça concerne des postes peu
qualifiés en beaucoup plus grand nombre
c'est-à-dire la masse des difficultés de
recrutement concerne quand même des
postes peu qualifiés et donc avec un
problème possible d'attractivité des
postes on observe ça dans les hôtels
cafés restaurants dans la construction
dans les aides à domicile etc
ces difficultés de recrutement peuvent
aboutir à des problèmes d'allocation des
facteurs c'est à dire que des
entreprises dynamiques ont une
difficulté de pour trouver la main
d'oeuvre qui leur serait nécessaire pour
croître main d'oeuvre qui serait
davantage capté par des entreprises un
petit peu moins dynamiques alors on a
fait une étude là-dessus qui est parue
dans économie statistique à la fin de
l'année dernière
basée sur une enquête réalisée par la
Banque de France et ce qu'on observe mes
coteurs et moi en travaillant sur ces
données individuelles c'est que les
firmes avec des difficultés de
recrutement sont effectivement plus
productives que les autres et cet écart
de productivité pas négligeable il est
d'environ
7%. mais sous des hypothèses très
simplistes si on supposé que les
entreprises avec difficulté de
recrutement trouver d'un coup de
baguette magique tous les effectifs dont
elles ont besoin parce que dans
l'enquête on demandait l'importance de
ces difficultés de recrutement le nombre
de postes concernés et si on fait de la
règle de trois pour voir un peu la
croissance auquel pourrait prétendre etc
l'effet sur la productivité moyenne dans
l'industrie serait assez faible 0,15 %.
donc à un véritable problème
d'allocation des ressources mais
néanmoins ce problème d'allocation des
ressources au niveau macroéconomique sur
la performance globale de l'économie ne
semble pas avoir des conséquences très
fortes sur le niveau moyen de la
productivité alors ces difficultés de de
recrutement peuvent venir de problèmes
d'attractivité l'attractivité peut être
salariale dans l'enquête de la Banque de
France à laquelle je faisais allusion
précédemment et qu'on a exploité avec
des données individuelles beaucoup
d'entreprises 54% de celles qui ont des
difficultés de recrutement nous disent
que effectivement c'est peut-être en
partie liée à une rémunération
insuffisante à l'embauche alors on
constate effectivement que ces
entreprises payent moins que la moyenne
des entreprises des mêmes des mêmes
secteurs mais simultanément on constate
que ces entreprises sont dans une
situation financière un peu moins
favorable que les autres et ce qui peut
expliquer évidemment leurs difficultés
augmenter les rémunérations
ces difficultés de recrutement peuvent
tout être aussi liées à des questions de
conditions de travail pénibilité 31% des
des entreprises qui déclarent des
difficultés de recrutement dans
l'enquête mentionné précédemment signal
ce
facteur explicatif de leurs difficultés
de recrutement et là évidemment ces
questions de pénibilité relèvent
beaucoup de la négociation collective du
dialogue social entre les partenaires
sociaux c'est d'ailleurs quelque chose
qui est en cours dans certaines branches
d'activités comme les hôtels qui a fait
restaurant pour donner un exemple bien
connu de de discussion et de négociation
en cours sur la question alors il faut
quand même signaler que ces difficultés
de recrutement peuvent être aussi liés à
une offre de travail insuffisamment
dynamique
insuffisamment dynamique
lié à une
insuffisance de la mobilité géographique
de l'offre de travail on pourra y
revenir mais la mobilité géographique de
l'offre de travail est très faible en
France
je développerai ça si vous le si vous le
souhaitez il peut y aussi avoir un
problème de distance insuffisante entre
les revenus du travail pour des postes
peu qualifiés et les revenus associés au
non travail et donc là il faut réfléchir
à des pistes de de réformes qui
augmenterait évidemment l'intérêt
l'attractivité financière de de ces
postes et puis il peut y avoir
avait suivi parfois
insuffisant au niveau individuel des
personnes en recherche d'emploi et du
caractère actif de leur recherche
d'emploi quelque chose qui est largement
souligné donc tout ça appelle évidemment
une réflexion éventuellement des
réformes ça inspire des réformes comme
celle de l'indemnisation chômage comme
celle du RSA
s'inspire aussi des des réformes comme
celle de de Pôle emploi c'est des pistes
qu'il faut considérer d'une façon je
dirais
sereine pour pour voir si effectivement
ces éléments pourraient jouer dernier
point de cette intervention liminaire
les économistes souvent regardent le
fonctionnement du marché du travail en
mobilisant quelques outils et l'un de
ces outils c'est ce qu'on appelle les
courbes de beveridges qui qui mettent en
relation sur un cadran les difficultés
de recrutement avec le taux de chômage
et plus on est élevé dans ce cadran plus
à singulariserait ça serait la marque
d'un mauvais certainement du marché du
travail bien quand on trace ces courbes
riches c'est ce qu'on a fait dans dans
l'article qu'on a publié dans économie
statistique à la fin de l'an dernier
quand on trace ses courbes de beveridges
et qu'on les compare entre les grands
pays européens les 5 grands pays
européens Allemagne France - Italie -
Espagne et Pays-Bas on voit que la
France est quand même assez élevée ce
qui serait le symptôme comme ça avec
quelques prudents bien sûr ce qui serait
le symptôme d'un fonctionnement du
marché du travail moins performant que
dans d'autres pays et en particulier en
Allemagne ou au Pays-Bas moins
performant ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que pour le même taux de chômage on
connaîtrait des difficultés de
recrutement supérieurs à celles que
connaissent les entreprises allemandes
et néerlandaises par exemple voilà donc
pour ce propos liminaire
merci Monsieur cette merci pour la
ponctualité 7 minutes très bien merci
beaucoup monsieur maverydice si vous
voulez laisse la parole je veux le même
temps
[Musique]
merci
donc je vais reprendre quelques quelques
points et peut-être répéter puisque ils
font partie d'un consensus
donc pour commencer d'abord il y a
y a on voit sur le marché du travail qui
a une présence simultanée de de chômage
et d'entreprises qui ont du mal à
recruter
ça a toujours été le cas ça fait partie
du processus d'appariement sur le marché
du travail
et mais en ce moment ce qui est assez il
y a deux grandes différences la première
c'est que les difficultés de recrutement
sont à un niveau beaucoup plus élevé que
précédemment et la deuxième c'est que
lorsqu'on regarde en comparaison dans
l'Union européenne comme la dit mon
collègue ici Monsieur giber 7 on a des
difficultés de recrutement qui sont
similaires à ceux des pays comme
l'Allemagne ou les Pays-Bas qui ont un
taux de chômage très faible et pourtant
on a un taux de chômage qui n'est pas si
faible que ça on a un taux de chômage
qui est beaucoup plus élevé et donc
structurellement ce que ce que l'on voit
c'est qu'on a au cours du temps des
difficultés de recrutement qui à taux de
chômage donné sont beaucoup plus élevés
que dans les autres pays européens donc
on a un marché de travail qui fonctionne
dont l'appariement est beaucoup moins
beaucoup moins fluide beaucoup plus
difficile
est-ce que c'est un problème et donc là
ce que ce que le consensus Dick c'est
que c'est un problème c'est pas anodin
comme problème le problème il a des
conséquences réelles qui sont très
tangibles pour pour les entreprises et
pour les travailleurs
ces difficultés de recrutement elles ont
un impact tangible réel sur le
développement des entreprises elle elles
ont un impact sur la croissance des
entreprises sur les coûts de recrutement
sur le coût des entreprises puisque ça
prend du temps de chercher des
travailleurs
de trouver un bon matching et il y a
aussi des travailleurs qui ne trouvent
pas d'emploi et donc toute l'économie
est affectée et les ordres de grandeur
dans ma compréhension ne sont pas si
faibles que cela donc s'il y a 5 % des
recrutements qui n'ont pas eu lieu qui
pourraient avoir lieu c'est quand même
significatif par rapport à la masse
salariale totale de l'économie donc
c'est un problème important qui faudrait
traiter et donc comment traiter ce
problème quel devrait être les leviers
d'action publique pour pour résumer moi
je mets quatre grands leviers d'action
publique le premier ce serait
d'accroître les incitations à l'emploi
le deuxième serait d'avoir une politique
de formation tout au long de la vie
d'améliorer la politique de formation
tout au long de la vie
le troisième ce serait d'améliorer la
relation contractuelle de travail qui
est aussi
problématique en France par rapport aux
autres pays
et finalement le quatrième de soutenir
les entreprises particulièrement les
petites entreprises dans leur processus
de recrutement
donc pour reprendre les quatre leviers
un par un dans l'incitation à l'emploi
deux grands deux grands de grandes axes
ou observations
la première observation c'est qu'on a
des taux d'emploi parmi les moins élevés
ou les moins élevés pour les moins
qualifiés et pour les seniors de tous
les pays de l'OCDE
nos taux d'emploi des seniors nos
seniors quitte le marché du travail
beaucoup plus tôt
et surtout ils sont moitié plus élevés
moitié moins élevés que ceux qui ont les
taux d'emploi les plus élevés donc parmi
les 59 64 ans on allait tout donc là qui
sont à 30 33% à peu près alors kopéida
sont à 70%
c'est considérable lorsqu'on parle de
difficultés de recrutement on a la
moitié de la population d'une tranche
d'âge qui n'est plus sur le marché du
travail alors que rien ne laisserait
penser qu'il ne pourrait pas y être
on a des passerelles vers la retraite
qui sont beaucoup plus faciles
que dans les autres pays on a des règles
d'éligibilité au chômage qui dépendent
de l'âge alors que ça fait plusieurs
décennies que l'on recommande de de ne
plus avoir ce genre de règles parce que
ce sont des passerelles
du travail via l'inactivité à la
retraite
on a ensuite
comme deuxième donc comme incitation à
l'emploi
la même remarque que mon collègue c'est
que l'emploi le travail doit payer plus
que l'inactivité on a en France des taux
marginaux d'imposition sur le travail
qui sont très élevés surtout pour les
moins qualifiés
et donc c'est aussi une désincitation à
l'emploi donc on aurait la possibilité
d'augmenter l'offre de travail
considérablement et ça pourrait avoir un
impact sur les difficultés de
recrutement
ensuite sur la formation
notre politique de formation
[Musique]
n'est pas centré sur tout le long de la
vie on a une formation initiale de base
qui est relativement performante
là où la France a du mal à rattraper les
autres pays c'est sur la formation tout
au long de la vie on forme moins souvent
les travailleurs que dans les autres
pays de l'OCDE donc
lorsqu'on pose la question est-ce que
vous avez suivi une formation au cours
des 12 derniers mois en France c'est à
peu près 20% des travailleurs dans les
autres pays d'ocde c'est 40%. on forme
moins souvent les travailleurs
l'accès à la formation et aussi inégal
alors il est inégal dans tous les pays
du monde il est né allant tout le hit de
CDE
on n'a pas des écarts qui soient
différents on a les mêmes inégalités que
que
mais surtout nos formations sont peu
alignées sur le besoin des entreprises
lorsqu'on demande aux entreprises est-ce
que les formations qui ont suivi vos
travailleurs qui les ont suivis elles
sont moins nombreuses ils sont nombreux
à avoir suivi des formations mais
lorsqu'on leur pose la question moins de
10%
disent que les formations étaient
alignées sur sur leurs besoins lorsqu'on
pose la question aux travailleurs c'est
moins de 50% et on est sur à chaque fois
dans l'extrême de la distribution des
pays de l'OCDE dans l'extrême négatif
donc les formations sont peu alignées ne
sont pas toujours utiles et le
financement est aussi un problème c'est
un financement est contraignant
donc ça c'est pour la formation
deux autres points améliorer la relation
du travail
nos indices de protection de l'emploi
sont toujours parmi les plus élevés de
l'OCDE malgré les réformes
qui ont été positives et qui nous ont
amenés à baisser cet indice de
protection de l'emploi
ces réformes ont eu un effet mais pas
énorme non plus on a on a bougé dans le
bon sens comme la plupart des pays de
l'OCDE mais donc lorsqu'on regarde les
distributions de nos indices de
protection de l'emploi on est toujours à
la même place relative malgré nos
efforts de réforme
ces indices
ils ont un effet sur sur le risque lié à
l'emploi à l'embauche sur le risque lié
au recrutement et donc il ne fluidifie
pas la relation et ils rendent les
recrutements peut-être plus incertains
et pèse de façon peut-être même
subjective sur les entreprises
le subjectif toujours quelque chose
d'important dans les surtout pour les
PME qui ont peur de commencer les
recrutements
et finalement notre soutien aux
entreprises nos travaux ont montré que
les
que les les PME n'ont plus l'entreprise
est grande moins à la de difficultés
liées au recrutement puisqu'elles ont
plus de ressources pour faire face à ces
difficultés mais les petites entreprises
souffrent plus des difficultés de
recrutement et ne sont pas peut-être ne
sont pas suffisamment suivies
suffisamment aidés par les pouvoirs
publics
et aussi les entreprises en périphérie
merci beaucoup
Monsieur Laurent
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président
moi je vais vous apporter des bonnes
nouvelles
parmi les causes que le la théorie
économique
présente souvent pour les difficultés de
recrutement il y en a nous identifiant
en général 5 il y en a quatre qui ont
déjà été évoqué ce matin donc je vais
pas y revenir rapidement mais c'est
l'inadéquation géographique ni
l'adéquation des compétences les
problèmes d'attractivité
le problème d'offre de travail qui était
déjà évoqué donc par les précédents
intervenants et le cinquième nous qu'on
identifie c'est le dynamisme intrinsèque
du marché du travail quand le marché du
travail fonctionne bien les entreprises
recrutent beaucoup elles recrutent
souvent et c'est une cause qui c'est une
phénomène qui peut causer aussi des
difficultés de recrutement on comprend
assez bien quand toutes les entreprises
de votre secteurs ont viennent de
recruter quelqu'un parce que le secteur
est en forme vous avez d'avoir un peu
plus de mal à trouver le chômeur
disponible qui correspond exactement à
votre profil et inversement moi il y a
de chômeurs plus ça va être compliqué de
il va falloir chercher plus longtemps
peut-être sur des profils un peu
différents pour retrouver la personne
qui correspond à votre au profil que
vous attendez
et donc la bonne nouvelle c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le marché du travail en
France il est très dynamique donc là il
y aura quelques courbes qui qui vont
vous montrer l'emploi salarié a repris
son dynamisme
et la retrouver la tendance qu'il avait
avant la crise covid aujourd'hui on crée
encore 100 millions d'emplois par
trimestre un rythme quand même très
soutenu avec un climat de l'emploi qui
est très élevé on a un taux d'activités
qui est au plus haut historique l'Insee
n'a jamais mesuré un taux d'activité
aussi au qu'aujourd'hui donc c'est porté
à la fois par la hausse du de l'emploi
des seniors
avec le recul de l'âge de départ à la
retraite effectivement il y a quand même
même si on est encore parmi les pays
où le taux d'emploi est le plus faible
parmi nos voisins européens il
progressent et c'est porté aussi par les
gènes avec notamment l'apprentissage qui
a ramené beaucoup de jeunes sur le
marché du travail
le donc le taux d'emploi et lui aussi un
niveau qui qui est le plus haut
historiquement mesuré et le taux de
chômage le graphique suivant le taux de
chômage lui a un niveau historique en
bas on est revenu au niveau de 2008 et
voilà depuis les crises pétrolières
c'est un niveau qui est un peu le
plancher de de l'économie française
alors il stagne un petit peu là depuis
depuis un an mais on a un niveau de
cette et demi pour cent qui est quand
même historiquement bas pour la pour
l'économie française donc
de ce point de vue là on peut dire que
le marché du travail est très dynamique
et que on est plutôt sur sur une
situation favorable mais effectivement
il y a en conséquence en fait de ce
cycle favorable des difficultés de
recrutement qui ont augmenté mais si on
regarde bien le le
les dynamiques temporelles on voit que
tout commence au même moment en 2015
enfin 2015 début 2016 au moment où le
chômage cette fameuse courbe du chômage
c'est inversée
les difficultés de recrutement elle
commence à augmenter à ce moment-là
aussi et donc on a vraiment un effet qui
est très qui est très bien expliqué par
la théorie économique quand le taux de
chômage diminue quand l'emploi et
l'activité reprennent ça devient de plus
en plus difficile pardon de recruter
parce que il y a moins de moins d'oeuvre
immédiatement disponible parce que il y
a une concurrence un peu accrue entre
les entreprises etc donc ça c'est le
point principal c'est que on a un
phénomène pardon qui est plutôt témoin
d'un dynamisme du marché du travail
nous notre le point qui nous a fait un
peu entrer sur ce sur ce sujet là cet
été c'est le point suivant c'est les
démissions effectivement c'était évoqué
un peu en introduction les démissions
aussi ont augmenté mais là encore c'est
un espèce d'effet un peu mécanique vous
faites quand les tensions de recrutement
augmentent ça rééquilibre ou ça
déséquilibre le rapport de négociation
en tout cas c'est le modifier entre les
salariés et les employeurs on sent bien
que quand il y a des difficultés à
recruter la situation est un peu plus
favorable pour les salariés et quand la
situation est plus favorable pour les
salariés ça veut dire que démissionner
moins risqué ça veut dire qu'on a aussi
des opportunités pour changer d'emploi
nous ce qu'on voit c'est quand même si
les démissionnaires sont plus nombreux
en fait six mois après leur démission il
y en a encore 8 sur 10 qui sont en
emploi donc en fait ils changent de
travail mais effectivement
quand le nombre de chômeurs diminue que
vous avez besoin de recruter vous allez
chercher un profil vous pouvez aller le
chercher dans l'entreprise d'à côté et
donc s'il faut aller chercher quelqu'un
dans l'entreprise d'à côté ça va créer
une démission donc et en termes de
niveau donc on a des niveaux très élevés
effectivement historiquement on a aussi
a du plus haut les nombre de démission y
compris le démission de CDI un niveau
historiquement haut mais c'est
parfaitement en lien avec le niveau de
tension qu'on mesure par ailleurs ça y
est ça n'a pas changé même après le
covid on est à des niveaux qui sont
assez cohérents avec le reste de ce
qu'on observe sur le marché du travail
et peut-être pour finir sur une note
encore plus optimiste en tout cas du
point de vue des salariés donc comme je
disais ces tensions elles changent le le
rapport de force de négociation des
salariés et ça peut se traduire par deux
choses et qui rejoignent un peu les
questions d'attractivité aussi puisque
c'est quand même les leviers principaux
qu'on les employeurs pour pour résoudre
leurs propres difficultés de recrutement
c'est les salaires qui qui augmentent
donc il y a un effet très fort de
l'inflation mais on sent aussi quand
même que les salaires on observait un
peu avant la reprise de l'inflation une
augmentation de des salaires donc pour
attirer plus de gens on est un peu
obligé de monter les salaires et puis on
a aussi une amélioration des conditions
d'emplois il y a un peu moins de temps
partiel que qu'avant et quand on recrute
c'est plus souvent en CDI copain avant
l'on recrutement dans CDD on recule plus
directement en CDI
donc voilà une fois qu'on a dit ça on
n'a pas tout dit effectivement les
problèmes d'attractivité de certains
métiers les problèmes d'inadéquation
géographique de formation ils sont
toujours là le mon point principal c'est
à dire que la dynamique qu'on voit
actuellement cette croissance des
tensions elle elle est plutôt liée à la
dynamique du marché du travail et donc
elle est plutôt rassurante et normale ça
veut pas dire que en dessous on
sous-jacent il y a pas des problèmes
spécifiques sectorielles ou par métier
ou par région qui faillit traiter mais
en tout cas c'est pas la dynamique qui
doit nous inquiéter
aujourd'hui merci
merci alors on va finir notre tour de
table métaux de table à l'impératrice si
vous voulez
bien merci donc et si le mouvement de
démission qu'on observe depuis la
pandémie conjuguée aux difficultés de
recrutement dans nombreux secteurs
reflétaient finalement une profonde
insatisfaction
et un refusent finalement de supporter
des conditions de travail jugées
difficiles et que finalement les
augmentations de salaire ne
parviendraient pas à compenser la
difficulté
auquel sont confrontées les salariés
dans le travail c'est en tout cas ce que
nous amène à penser les résultats de
notre étude sur le sens du travail dont
je vais partager avec vous les
principaux résultats donc au préalable
il me faut préciser que on s'intéresse
au travail comme activité et pas à
l'emploi alors cette distinction est
importante car les politiques publiques
ont tendance à se focaliser sur l'emploi
son volume ses attributs la rémunération
le contrat de travail éventuellement les
droits sociaux auxquels il donne accès
mais à négliger l'activité de travail et
son intérêt intrinsèque pour les
travailleurs or et ça c'est un résultat
majeur des sciences du travail le
travail réel d'y faire toujours du
travail prescrit et la personne qui
travaille je vais surtout parler des
salariés ici mais toujours plus dans son
travail plus de temps plus de
compétences son intelligence sa
créativité que ce qui lui est
strictement demandé donc il s'engage
réellement dans le travail donc cette
question du sens du travail nous paraît
tout à fait importante et d'ailleurs
lorsque dans des études préalables on
interrogeait les salariés sur leur
rapport au travail souvent il nous
disait ça n'a plus de sens je ne trouve
plus de sens à mon travail donc c'est ça
qui est à l'origine de notre
questionnement qui est un questionnement
assez atypique pour pour des économistes
donc comment définit-on le sens du
travail alors pour nous un travail à
sens s'il donne à celui qu'il exerce le
sentiment d'être
utile c'est la première dimension si la
personne peut se reconnaître dans ce
qu'elle fait autrement dit si elle est
en capacité de pouvoir bien faire son
travail selon ses normes
professionnelles mais aussi selon
l'éthique commune donc c'est notre
deuxième dimension et la troisième
dimension c'est si elle peut exprimer
ses compétences si elle peut les
développer dans le travail c'est ce
qu'on appelle la capacité de
développement
alors évidemment
l'environnement professionnel offre plus
ou moins les conditions de production de
sens au travail j'y reviendrai et selon
les métiers les professions ce sont
certaines des dimensions du sens que je
viens dénoncer qui seront plus
particulièrement affectés et qui
conduiront à ce que le salarié trouve
moins de sens à son travail alors sur la
base de cette définition on a construit
un score individuel de sens du travail à
partir des réponses apportées donc par
un échantillon représentatif de salariés
du public et du privé à des questions de
l'enquête conditions de travail donc de
l'INSEE et de la DARES alors je ne
rentre pas dans le détail mais à titre
d'exemple donc c'est l'enquête condition
de travail 2016
27% des salariés n'ont que parfois ou
jamais l'impression de faire quelque
chose d'utile aux autres
26% n'éprouvent que parfois ou jamais la
fierté du travail bien fait ou encore
25% des salariés disent n'avoir que
parfois ou jamais l'occasion de
développer leur compétences dans le
travail
alors un premier niveau très descriptif
ce score de sens nous permet d'établir
un palmarès des professions et métiers
qui trouvent le plus de sens à leur
travail alors parmi les professions qui
trouvent le plus de sens en 2016 on
trouve les assistantes maternelles les
ouvriers qualifiés du gros œuvre du
bâtiment mais aussi les formateurs les
enseignants les aides à domicile les
aides ménagères alors pour cette
dernière profession
fort sentiment d'utilité sociale
mais faible capacité de développement on
s'en doute faible capacité de
développement mais en même temps
compenser par un plus fort score sur les
autres dimensions
alors on remarque dans ces professions
qui trouvent le plus de sens à leur
travail quelque chose quand même
d'intéressant c'est que le sens du
travail n'est pas la panache des
professions les plus qualifiées et les
plus exigeantes en diplôme elles ont
aussi souvent en commun ces professions
qui trouvent le plus de sens à leur
travail de travailler en relation avec
le public
et ça ça reste vrai toute chose égale
par ailleurs mais ce sont aussi des
professions qui peuvent être fragiles on
pense aux enseignants mais aussi aux
infirmières qui ne figurent pas dans le
palmarès des 15 professions qui trouvent
le plus de sens pourquoi parce que elles
ont un vrai déficit de cohérence éthique
autrement dit elles ne sont pas en
capacité de pouvoir bien faire leur
travail
donc voilà à quoi nous enfin ce que peut
nous permettre ce score du travail je
dis rapidement quels sont les
professions qui trouvent le moins de
sens à leur travail d'après nos calculs
en premier lieu les employés de la
banque et des assurances les ouvriers de
la manutention ceux des industries de
process les caissières les agents de
gardiennage et de sécurité les employés
et agents de maîtrise de l'hôtellerie
restauration surtout pour ces derniers
du fait d'une faible capacité de
développement
alors à caractéristique observer
similaire le sens du travail est en
moyenne plus élevé pour les cadres mais
aussi pour les salariés qui travaillent
dans des petits établissements moins de
50 salariés
il est aussi plus élevé pour ceux qui
travaillent dans la fonction publique et
dans les associations plutôt que dans le
secteur privé
j'ajoute que à métier
identique les femmes ne voient pas de
plus pas plus de sens à leur travail que
les hommes
et les plus de 50 ans ont un sentiment
d'utilité sociale et une cohérence
éthique plus élevée que les autres
salariés mais il y a pas d'effets
spécifiques pour les jeunes ici les
moins de 30 ans
alors de la manière dont le travail est
organisé dépend significativement le
sens que les salariés trouvent à leur
travail ainsi on montre que les
changements organisationnels récurrents
la fixation d'objectifs chiffrés sur
lesquels les salariés n'ont pas leurs
mots à dire le fait de travailler en
sous-traitance pour un donneur d'ordre
ces trois marqueurs de ce qu'on appelle
le management par les chiffres contribue
fortement à dégrader le sens du travail
bon par ailleurs nos résultats
confortent l’hypothèse d'un lien entre
faible sens du travail et des missions à
caractéristique observé similaire la
probabilité de quitter son emploi est
accrue de 30% pour les salariés qui
trouvent peu de sens à leur travail
d'autres dimensions des conditions de
travail joue aussi également comme être
exposé à une forte intensité du travail
manquer de soutien hiérarchique mais ne
trouvez peu de sens à son travail reste
le facteur le plus fort
par contre avoir le sentiment d'être mal
payé n'a pas d'effet statistiques
significatif sur la probabilité de
quitter son emploi toutes choses égales
par ailleurs
j'ajoute en lien avec la thématique de
la formation et des compétences que
parmi les dimensions du sens c'est la
capacité de développement qui est
particulièrement corrélée à la décision
de mobilité
alors et pour ceux qui ne peuvent pas
partir
nous mettons en évidence que face à un
travail qui perd de son sens la
probabilité d'être absent pour maladie
s'accroît significativement en termes
d'incidence mais aussi en termes de
nombre de jours
alors se pose ainsi la question de la
soutenabilité du travail pour ceux qui
travaillent dans des conditions qui ne
permettent pas de construire du sens
alors je ferai juste je mentionnerai
quand même la question de
l'environnement on sait que la crise
écologique tarotte de plus en plus les
consciences on a profité du fait que
dans l'enquête condition de travail 2019
une question avait été introduite on
demandait aux salariés s'ils avaient le
sentiment par leur travail de contribuer
à nuire à l'environnement on a appelé ça
le conflit éthique environnemental c'est
7% des salariés qui répondent souvent de
voir par leur travail dégradé
l'environnement et bien nous montrons
que ce sont ces salariés qui plus
probablement disent aussi qu'ils ne
pourront pas tenir leur travail jusqu'à
la retraite
et c'est une autre question de l'enquête
condition de travail qu'ils envisagent
une bifurcation professionnelle
changement de métier ou de profession
dans les trois ans qui viennent donc
c'est aussi une dimension que que je
porte à votre connaissance elle me
semble importante et puis plus
globalement trouver peu de sens à son
travail multiplie par deux la
probabilité de déclarer ne pas pouvoir
faire le même travail jusqu'à la
retraite
c'est un facteur aussi important qu'être
parmi les salariés les plus exposés à la
pénibilité physique ou au travail
intensif
donc au total nos résultats corrobores
et complètent ceux déjà mis en évidence
par la Dares sur le rôle des conditions
de travail dans les difficultés que
rencontre les employeurs dans certains
secteurs à recruter mais aussi à
fidéliser leurs salariés
et ce faisant nous mettons l'accent je
pense sur une dimension des risques
psychosociaux que l'on peut considérer
comme émergente
alors en mettant au premier plan du
débat public la question de l'utilité
sociale des métiers avec les métiers
essentiels la pandémie a sans doute
renforcée un questionnement qui était
déjà présent sur le sens du travail
merci beaucoup merci à chacun d'avoir
ouvert le débat par vos interventions
donc je vais laisser la parole aux
rapporteur peut-être commencer par
Michel caneve puisqu'il a travaillé à
deux reprises sur ce thème et qu'il a
évidemment une vision
dans le temps de ces sujets Michel merci
beaucoup madame messieurs pour vos
éclairages extrêmement intéressants
effectivement on est à un paradoxe ou
dans notre pays
nous avons un taux de chômage qui est
parmi le plus bas et beaucoup de
difficultés effectivement
énoncées par les entreprises pour le
recrutement vous avez évoqué beaucoup de
facteurs à ce sujet vous n'avez pas
évoqué
la question de la formation initiale
est-elle adéquate pour faire face aux
besoins des entreprises parce que dans
les études préalables qu'on a effectuées
euh la question de l'adéquation de la
formation initiale le besoin des acteurs
économiques c'est constamment posé je
veux dire par là notamment la capacité
d'adaptation de l'éducation nationale au
besoin effectivement d'emploi des
entreprises et on a sans doute beaucoup
de choses à faire a été évoqué tout à
l'heure aussi
la question de la difficulté de
recrutement notamment d'un industrie
vous savez que dans les politiques
publiques du gouvernement il y a la
volonté de réindustrialiser la France
comment va-t-on pouvoir permettre la
réindustrialisation de la France sachant
qu'aujourd'hui déjà 80% des entreprises
dans le secteur de l'industrie énoncent
des difficultés de recrutement ce qui
peut nous poser problème un autre sujet
récurrent porte sur la question des
écarts de revenus entre le travail et
les prestations de de solidarité c'est
vrai qu'on a toujours le sentiment que
est-ce que selon vous la récente réforme
de la l'assurance chômage et de nature
apporter des correctifs à ces dégâts
vous voyez vous d'autres modifications à
apporter à cette observation de l'écart
entre les
entre la
les revenus d'assistance et et les
revenus effectivement du travail sur la
question du recrutement des TPE vous
avez évoqué les difficultés
d'accompagnement pourtant une réforme a
eu lieu changeant l'ANPE et la cédé
qu'en Pôle Emploi voilà quelques années
est-ce que ça veut dire que pour
l'emploi dans sa mission n'est pas
suffisamment centrée sur les besoins des
entreprises peut-être que les grosses
entreprises ont des structures de
ressources humaines à même de pouvoir
être totalement indépendant y compris en
recourant à des cabinets de recrutement
mais est-ce que selon vous
l'organisation actuelle de
Pôle emploi et comment dirais-je adapté
aux besoins effectifs des entreprises et
est-ce que cela doit être un des
objectifs de la réforme annoncée par le
gouvernement qui visant à créer
effectivement France travail
parmi les difficultés de recrutement que
vous avez évoqué
est-ce qu'il y a un lien à effectuer
entre
cela et le haut niveau de création
d'entreprise dans notre pays parce que
finalement on s'aperçoit que celle-ci
est particulièrement dynamique en France
peut-être que un certain nombre de
personnes employables le soriantes
plutôt vers l'accréation d'entreprise
qui peut être aussi un facteur de
dynamisme de l'activité et donc
prometteur pour pour l'avenir
effectivement voilà et puis peut-être
une dernière question sur la question de
l'apprentissage puisque c'était dans nos
rapports antérieurs un des sujets
majeurs de préoccupation le faible
niveau de recours à l'apprentissage et
cela a fortement évolué en 5 ans
puisqu'on est passé de 400 à 800 000
apprentis dans notre pays
est-ce que selon vous
cette évolution du nombre d'apprentis
s'est effectué vers une cible effective
de
direction vers le travail ou est-ce que
ce sont des effets de opportunités qui
se manifestent à travers cela merci
merci Michel donc de très nombreuses
questions qui veut qui veut commencer
monsieur 7 peut-être sur la formation
j'ai pas répondre à tout puisque les
autres intervenants sont plus compétents
que moi pour répondre à certains aspects
taux de chômage bas d'accord pour
expliquer les difficultés de recrutement
en partie c'est l'un des plus bas
il faut remonter loin disons pour
retrouver un taux de chômage aussi bas
il est quand même élevé
comparons-nous à l'ensemble des pays de
l'OCDE on fait quand même partie des
pays à fort taux de chômage puis si on
regarde au-dessus de la palissade du
village France et qu'on voit comment se
comporte le marché du travail dans
d'autres pays on voit un pays comme
l'Italie qui est souvent pas considéré
comme un benchmark pour le
fonctionnement de son marché du travail
ou taux de chômage n'est pas très
différent d'une autre un tout petit peu
supérieur mais pas très très différent
d'une autre où il est orienté à la
baisse comme chez nous et où les
difficultés de recrutement sont
régulièrement plus basse faut quand même
faut quand même souligner ça pour pour
accentuer aussi la chose
les difficultés de recrutement dans le
secteur de la construction sont
structurellement parce que c'est pas
quelque chose de récent structurellement
plus élevé en France qu'en Allemagne et
qu'au Pays-Bas ou le je la coupe sous
les yeux ou taux de chômage pourtant est
à environ 3% vous vous le savez donc il
y a quand même un ensemble de symptômes
de difficultés spécifiques du
fonctionnement du marché du travail en
France ça c'est un premier point
deuxième point certes la formation et
c'est une dimension très importante de
la de la question cela va de soi il faut
voir que la masse des difficultés de
recrutement concerne la masse concerne
des postes très peu qualifiés HCR
construction et même service à la
personne donc
il y a une réponse du côté de la
formation le caractère massif la plus
grande masse des difficultés de
recrutement ne relèvent pas de ça alors
pour
juste pour pour être très direct dans
dans la réponse à votre question sur la
réforme de la l'indemnisation chômage et
le seuil des 9% sous lequel
la durée d'indemnisation est réduite
c'est sans doute un second best mais
vaut mieux un second best que pas de
baisse du tout évidemment le premier
baisse ça serait un suivi
individualisé
exigeant et bienveillant de chaque
personne
au chômage ça serait ça le premier Best
parce que ça pourrait prendre en compte
les spécificités de la qualification des
activités des etc de ce qui se passe
dans localement bon à partir du moment
où ce premier Best first best est
difficile à atteindre encore une fois
vaut mieux un second best que pas de
baisse du tout et pour se rapprocher
d'un first best évidemment
il faut envisager une forte réforme de
l'indemnisation
enfin sans doute du fonctionnement de
Pôle emploi c'est en train de se faire
un dans le fonctionnement de Pôle emploi
il y a une réflexion qu'on peut avoir
qui qui est sur la table quand même sur
le dressage et j'ai pas de d'avis fort
là-dessus parce que faut regarder comme
les choses sur le fond pas avoir de
position a priori faut regarder ça de
façon de façon sereine voyez il y a
beaucoup de dimensions aborder qui ont
été évoqués par par mon par mon voisin
qui sont importants il y a un point
quand même qui a été souligné d'ailleurs
par mon voisin qui est essentiel
le taux d'emploi en France et bas pour
certaines catégories de population et
c'est pas un problème de taux de chômage
le taux d'emploi est bas pour les
seniors leur taux de chômage est plus
bas que celui de la moyenne de la de la
population de l'ensemble de la
population donc c'est pas un problème de
taux de chômage c'est un problème de
comportement d'activités il faut bien
voir que quand on parle de tôle emploi
faible au niveau global de l'ensemble de
la population en âge de travailler de 15
à 64 ans disons pour faire pour faire
simple pour regarder statistiques on est
à 10 points en dessous de certains pays
donc ça ça fait de la richesse en moins
ça fait de ça fait du pouvoir d'achat au
moins ça fait des possibilités de
financement des rentrées fiscales en
moins c'est beaucoup de choses en moi
une bonne partie de nos difficultés
qu'elle soit de finance publique qu'elle
soit de pouvoir d'achat etc peuvent
s'expliquer par cet écart de tôle emploi
et cet écart de tôle emploi c'est un
comportement d'activité principalement
d'activité principalement puisque encore
une fois le taux de chômage est faible
sur les sur les seniors
France donc voilà la difficulté quand
même est là la touche positive parce
qu'il faut quand même donner une touche
positive c'est que pour aller à la serpe
sur les 20 dernières années le taux
d'emploi des seniors a augmenté de
quasiment un point par an en France
c'est une évolution faramineuse un point
par an d'augmentation du taux d'emploi
des seniors faut rester sur cette pente
au moins sur cette pente faut avoir
cette ambition de rester sur cette pente
et derrière le fait de rester sur cette
porte il y a du pouvoir d'achat il y a
de la richesse il y a du PI bien une
amélioration des finances publiques il y
a énormément de choses qui qui sont qui
sont en jeu
merci sur les autres points évoqués par
Michel carrivet voulait monsieur
Maurice
je veux bien très rapidement sur le
sur l'évolution de l'emploi des seniors
c'est vrai qu'on a une évolution
positive très positive
on était à sur les sur les 60 64 ans on
était à 10% on est donc maintenant
presque 30 mètres
on est dans la moyenne de l'évolution
des autres pays de l'OCDE donc on
partait ont du plus bas on était le pays
avec le taux d'emploi des seniors le
plus faible on l'est toujours mais on a
la même évolution positive que les
autres pays donc on n'est pas on n'est
pas fantastique
ça c'est un deux sur la question de la
formation initiale je partage
la vie je pense que Monsieur Satan la
même chose je pense que c'est surtout
une question de
de formation au long de la vie que les
problèmes de difficulté de recrutement
ils sont pour beaucoup de métiers non
qualifiés donc je ne pense pas qu'il
faille mettre
le focus sur les sur la formation
initiale
tous les tous les indicateurs nous
montrent qu'on ait quelque part dans la
moyenne que c'est c'est pas la formation
unipal initiale n'est pas le problème
ici qui
n'est pas le problème
et
se centrer plutôt sur le recours à
l'apprentissage
dans les réformes récentes
tout indiquerait qu'elles sont très
positives à la fois par la quantité de
personnes qui rentrent en apprentissage
et sur le et sur le ciblage
je ne sais pas quels sont concrètement
les personnellement je ne suis pas au
courant des effets donc je ne sais pas
s'il y a eu une évaluation là dessus
on peut pas me prendre
et pour finir sur les sur le sur l'écart
de revenus entre le travail et les
prestations d'assistance on a un sujet
particulièrement français là dessus et
donc pour augmenter l'offre de travail
il faut que le travail paye plus que
l'inactivité
on a des minimas
d'assistance qui sont parmi les plus
élevés qui c'est quelque chose de
positif mais la contrepartie est que du
coup le taux marginal d'imposition
au travail pour les pour les plus pour
les moins qualifiés pour ceux qui sont
en bas de la distribution des revenus
paradoxalement du coup il est plus élevé
que pour les plus que pour les plus
riches et donc
et donc le taux marginal d'imposition
c'est
lorsque quelqu'un décide de travailler à
la marge une heure de plus quels sont
quel est le quel est son son
augmentation de revenus par rapport aux
rapports à ce qu'il reçoit comme comme
salaire et donc lorsqu'on voit que le
pour les faibles revenus augmenter
l'offre de travail veut dire évidemment
renoncer à des minimas sociaux et donc
on trouve un taux marginal de
d'imposition sur le travail qui est plus
élevé que pour les plus riches dans le
pays et donc c'est une désincitation au
travail qui qui est plus élevé que pour
que pour ceux qui sont très formés ou
pour ceux qui gagnent très bien leur vie
et donc il faut oui
pour les personnes
plus important
pour les gens c'est bien c'est bien
c'est
les taux d'imposition
mais pour ceux qui ne seraient pas pour
ceux qui ne seraient pas en travail donc
pour ceux qui se répands au travail
lorsqu'on veut augmenter on veut
augmenter l'offre de travail pour
réduire les difficultés de recrutement
et donc il y a un vivier de personnes
qui sont en inactivité parmi les seniors
parmi les moins qualifiés mais en même
temps on a pour ces personnes là on a
des Minimes associés qui sont élevés
auxquels il n'aurait pas le droit
lorsqu'il lorsqu'il décide à la marge
entre
passer de l'inactivité au travail et
donc pour eux le travail c'est souvent
peut-être se lever à 3h30 du matin ou
4h30 du matin s'il faut faire les
marchés s'il faut aller sur un chantier
de construction
si c'est pour avoir un taux marginal de
d'imposition qui est de 70% parce qu'on
parce qu'on
renonce à les minima sociaux c'est taux
d'imposition sont plus élevés que pour
les personnes qui sont
mais si je peux il y a juste un point
d'explication
des prestations
c'est en fait c'est essentiellement lié
à la dégressivité des prestations c'est
comme les prestations
ah non non personne ne dit que c'est une
situation normale mais comme les
présidents social pour bien comprendre
mais je veux pas je veux pas
prendre tout le débat mais vous êtes en
train de dire que le minima social c'est
la référence et que on se prive de la
référence si on va travailler c'est ça
quand on travaille il y a des revenus du
travail mais il y a une perte de
prestation et donc les gains de la
prestation est est une situation plutôt
normale pour vous et le travail c'est
une c'est une dérogation
qui simplement une comparaison
statistique d'une situation avec des
revenus du travail et sans revenus du
travail il y a aucun jugement de valeur
là dedans c'est simplement une
comparaison
est importante
pour moi la référence n'est pas le
minimum
on voit simplement ce qui se passe pour
quelqu'un qui a des prestations
prestations dégressives et donc ces
prestations dégressives diminuent quand
ces revenus du travail augmentent et
bien quel est son gain à cette personne
à avoir des revenus du travail par
rapport aux prestations et bien c'est ce
qu'on appelle c'est ce qu'on met dans le
taux de prélèvement marginal
d'imposition puisqu'il perd des
prestations et le gain au passage au
travail doit prendre en compte
évidemment cette perte de prestation et
la France est un pays dans lequel les
prestations sont fortes pour pas que ça
coûte des fortunes elles sont évidemment
assez rapidement dégressives et bien ça
réduit la pétance enfin le gain
financier au travail c'est tout c'est un
simple constat statistique
et est-ce que des études ont été faites
justement pour limiter cet effet et pour
jouer sur une une dégressivité moindre
des aides pour limiter à la déscitation
au final
[Musique]
d'autres points allez-y oui juste sur la
question de des créations d'entreprise
pour nous c'est aussi un
symptôme d'un marché du travail qui est
d'une activité qui est dynamique par
ailleurs le premier de la première
courbe que je montrais l'emploi salarié
lui-même mais aussi à ses dynamique donc
c'est deux phénomènes qui sont qui vont
plutôt dans le même sens et qu'il faut
pas
l'un pour l'instant le sentiment que
c'est l'un se ferait au détriment de
l'autre les deux les deux progressent en
ce moment et sur
sur le LED au recrutement pour apporter
par exemple Pôle emploi
je pense que effectivement c'est un
outil qui peut être très utile alors je
me permettrai pas de savoir si de dire
si on en a assez ou trop mais dans un
contexte où et notamment les difficultés
sont liées au fait que il y a des
besoins de recrutement qui sont très
importants par rapport à quelques années
c'est important d'accompagner toutes les
entreprises et peut-être même les plus
petites c'est ce que ce qui évoquait
Gilbert aussi c'est peut-être des
problèmes d'allocations et les grandes
entreprises qui ont une force de frappe
peut-être un peu plus importante et sont
plus pour qu'il recrutement est plus
simple parce que ils ont un département
de ressources humaines qui est énorme
par rapport à une petite entreprise où
il y a 5 salariés personne n'est
vraiment dédié à ça c'était peut-être
dans ces petites entreprises là que la
productivité que les gains de
productivité sont et c'est peut-être ces
entreprises aussi qu'il faut aider à
recruter à trouver des salariés qui leur
permettront de se développer
oui je veux bien ajouter un mot sur la
question de la formation initiale alors
je partage ce qui a été dit du reste je
crois que c'est à peu près la moitié des
jeunes qui trouvent un emploi en
adéquation avec leur formation initiale
donc c'est moins le fait d'une
inadéquation et d'une insuffisance de de
du système éducatif que le fait que les
compétences qui sont demandées en
entreprise peuvent être spécifiques et
nécessité une adaptation etc j'aimerais
insister sur le fait que l'entreprise
peut être un environnement apprenant et
justement pour compenser peut-être les
faibles taux d'accès à la formation
quand on parle la France notamment aux
autres pays européens
peut-être là où la France a été un peu
en retard c'est en négligeant le fait
que le travail puisse être apprenant
donc la loi 2018 a créé la formation en
situation de travail ce serait
intéressant de voir comment les
entreprises s'en emparent pour former
justement et notamment
les nouvelles recrues et puis aussi en
lien avec le taux d'emploi des seniors
on sait que une partie des seniors ne
sont pas en emploi au moment de la
retraite ils sont obligés de par souvent
des conditions de travail difficiles et
le la faible adaptation aussi de leur
emploi au caractère enfin leur caractère
vieillissant de quitter le marché du
travail or et là je fais référence à un
travail de deux collègues à Corinne
Godard et Serge wolkov dans le travail
pressé il montre qu'en fait les
entreprises pourraient offrir au seniors
de nouveaux rôles au fur et à mesure de
l'avancée en âge notamment dans le
transfert de compétences la transmission
de de leur savoir par des tutorats des
ateliers formation en entreprise
ce serait une manière d'adapter
finalement leur poste et de faire
bénéficier de leur expérience
voilà les jeunes recrues et puis enfin
dernier élément en lien avec ce que j'ai
dit sur le sens du travail un des
principaux obstacles à la formation en
entreprise dans les différentes enquêtes
c'est la charge de travail et le temps
souvent des formations formelles sont
prévues et puis elles ne sont pas
suivies ou bien elles sont abandonnées
avant leur terme parce que le quotidien
de l'activité fait que le salarié n'a
pas le temps de se former donc là aussi
c'est quelque chose à avoir en tête pour
favoriser
la formation sur l'apprentissage
j'aurais juste dire un mot il me semble
que la forte croissance de
l'apprentissage que vous avez relaté
elle est en grande partie due à
l'apprentissage dans dans l'éducation
enfin dans le l'enseignement supérieur
et finalement très peu pour ceux à qui
l'apprentissage était initialement
destinée ça m'interroge sur la
pertinence du ciblage justement
voilà et puis peut-être
un dernier élément
sur le choix de travailler à son compte
dans les entretiens dans les travaux
notamment sociologiques ce qu'on voit de
quand même c'est que parfois travailler
à son compte est un moyen d'échapper aux
contraintes du travail salarié et
notamment aux contraintes horaires à
l'organisation temporelle du travail ce
serait aussi intéressant d'examiner la
question sous cet angle par exemple dans
la coiffure de plus en plus de d'anciens
salariés louent des fauteuils dans des
salons de coiffure pour pouvoir aménager
leur planning comme comme elle
l'entendent notamment pouvoir bénéficier
de certains samedis non travailler donc
là aussi c'est à mettre en relation avec
peut-être voilà les difficultés de
recrutement et de fidélisation j'insiste
sur cette question parce que
sont aussi des emplois les emplois peu
qualifiés qui sont exposés à des
difficultés de recrutement sont souvent
aussi ceux qui connaissent un fort
turnover donc l'idée c'est de recruter
mais c'est aussi de pouvoir garder
finalement ces salariés
si continuer avec Martine Berthet pour
un porteur oui merci monsieur le
président madame messieurs merci
beaucoup pour ces éléments que vous nous
apportez alors moi j'aurais peut-être
pour rebondir sur les propos de Madame
Perez donc vous parlez voilà certains
salariés louent des fauteuils etc dans
des salons moi je voudrais parler
justement du rôle des autos
entrepreneurs dans ce manque de
compétences et de recrutement pour les
entreprises on l'a vu et la délégation
aux entreprises a fait un travail sur ce
sujet la plateformeisation du travail
voilà l'augmentation du nombre
d'auto-entrepreneurs est-ce que cela
parce qu'on ne voit également dans les
secteurs de l'hôtellerie restauration ou
finalement il n'y a plus de recrutement
possible mais beaucoup de d'ateliers
restaurateurs passent par un système de
plateformes et vont signer des contrats
plutôt de prestations avec
alors des personnes qui ne seront pas là
comme salariés mais comme bien comme
auto-entrepreneur cela a pris beaucoup
d'ampleur on l'a vu encore plus après la
crise sanitaire est-ce que vous pensez
que cela joue déjà un rôle dans ces
manques de recrutement de salariés
c'est ma première question ensuite on
voit qu'il y a des écoles de la seconde
chance des MLJ des dispositifs
d'insertion qu'elle part est-ce qu'ils
peuvent prendre tous ces dispositifs
dans la formation dans le recrutement de
nouveaux salariés est-ce que cela aussi
vous l'avez évalué et est-ce que ces
dispositifs doivent être augmentés
j'ai une remarque aussi monsieur 7 où
nous avait parlé de la difficulté de la
mobilité géographique dans notre pays
c'est quelque chose enfin c'est une
chose pour laquelle je milite je vais
dire pour que l'on puisse faciliter
cette mobilité géographique dans mon
département de la Savoie nous sommes à
5,6% de taux de chômage et là on peut
dire que l'on arrive un taux plancher
même si je pense que ce taux plancher
devrait plutôt être prêt de 3 à 4% et
pas plus
la mobilité géographique on le voit et
intéressante on a connu ce phénomène
dans les années je dirais 80 90 ou
beaucoup de personnes de secteurs
industriels sont venus en Savoie trouver
de l'emploi et c'était très bien est-ce
que l'on ne peut pas mettre de
l'incitation à votre avis sur cette
mobilité qu'est-ce qui peut être fait
pour faciliter cette mobilité de bassin
dans lesquels il y a peu d'emplois vers
des bassins en recherche et puis
peut-être ma dernière question et vous
en avez vous l'avez évoqué aussi donc
nous avons travaillé sur nous
travaillons puisque c'est un travail qui
est suivi sur la responsabilité
sociétale des entreprises et justement
cette mise en avant est-ce qu'il y a
cette recherche
vous sentez de la part des
au niveau des au moment des embauches
donc cette recherche de
d'entreprises qui est mis en oeuvre
cette RSE de meilleure pas seulement
meilleure condition de travail mais
aussi une préoccupation
des conséquences de l'activité
d'entreprise vis-à-vis de
l'environnement merci
[Musique]
façon très rapide sur la mobilité
géographique on voit des symptômes de
faible mobilité c'est quand on voit les
cartes de taux de chômage par bassin
d'emploi c'est assez étonnant parce
qu'on voit des bassins d'emploi Michael
c'est mieux que moi combien il y en a je
n'ai plus le chiffre en tête 300 donc
vous voyez c'est quand même assez fin
déjà on voit des bassins d'emploi fortes
chômage qui sont juste à côté
limitrophes de bassin d'emploi à faible
taux de chômage donc déjà c'est le
symptômes d'une faible mobilité
géographique mais pire encore quand on
compare cette carte aujourd'hui avec la
même carte il y a 20 ans c'est les mêmes
c'est les mêmes c'est-à-dire que en 20
ans enfin ça se ressemble beaucoup en
tout cas et en 20 ans vous voyez il y a
pas eu de mobilité géographique forte
c'est quelque chose de détonnant alors
derrière il y a des problèmes de de
transport il y a des problèmes de
politique de logements sociales aussi
des gens qui veulent pas lâcher un
logement social dans dans un lieu
même si leurs conditions d'emploi bon il
y a un tas de politiques qui sont
concernés par cette faible mobilité
géographique il faut réfléchir mais en
tout cas il y a un tas de dimensions
derrière sur les auto-entrepreneurs j'ai
pas regardé les derniers frémissements
statistiques dont vous parlez mais
j'avais beaucoup regardé ça jusqu'à
l'année 2021 on voit que dans l'ensemble
des pays de l'OCDE la part de des de
l'emploi non salarié dans l'emploi total
est en baisse
sauf dans trois pays de l'OCDE qui sont
les Pays-Bas le Royaume-Uni et la France
et ces trois pays singularisent par le
fait d'avoir mis en oeuvre des
politiques incitatives justement à
l'auto-entrepreneuriat que ce soit
incitatif réglementaire que soit
incitatif fiscal ou ou autre alors c'est
quelque chose qui interroge parce
qu'effectivement les des
auto-entrepreneurs parfois qui sont dans
des situations de subordination très
fortes n'ont pas les
nous allons montrer que globalement au
niveau macroéconomique le développement
de ce type d'emploi
n'aboutissait pas à plus d'emplois dans
des pays comme la France comme les
Pays-Bas comme le Royaume-Uni c'était
insignifiant donc il y a pas de façon
forte un développement de l'emploi par
cela mais enfin ça reste au niveau
macroéconomique très réduit il faut
quand même en voir la la marque et la
crainte d'une substitution autre emploi
salarié emploi non salarié par de ce
fait et quand même doit quand même être
écarté
vous poursuivez je veux bien reprendre
sur la question de la mobilité c'est une
question
fondamentale très importante et comme
comme vient de le rappeler mon collègue
gerset lorsqu'on prend les cartes de
zone d'emploi maintenant et à 20 ans
celles qui sont en tension sont les
mêmes qu'il y a 20 ans et elles sont pas
loin de autres zones d'emploi qui qui
sont pas en tension
je voudrais juste rappeler que tout est
fait en France tout pour entraver la
mobilité toutes nos politiques
principalement trois la politique
fiscale la politique du logement et les
PLU
donc les pluies
ça ne dépendent pas du gouvernement mais
ça dépend des collectivités locales mais
très souvent on a très peu le droit de
construire donc vous avez un taux de
chômage à 5% en Savoie les conditions
pour la construction de plus de
logements en savoir sont très compliqués
la politique fiscale lorsque les
travailleurs dans les zones
qui ont des taux de chômage élevés
veulent déménager aller en Savoie
ils doivent louer s'ils sont
propriétaires doivent louer il doit
faire louer leur leur logement ils sont
taxés sur le logement qui vont faire
louer
et à des taux marginaux très élevés
puisque ce sont des revenus qui se
rajoutent à leurs revenus de travail
alors que avant il ne l'était pas et
donc on taxe la mobilité puisque on
empêche les gens de venir s'installer
dans les endroits qui sont en tension
s'il décide de ne pas louer leur leur
logement et de le vendre là ils sont
taxés sur la totalité de leur avoir qui
en général donc pour les pour les
familles en français le logement c'est
le seul à voir financier qu'ils ont ils
sont axés sur non pas sur un flux de
revenus mais ça peut près 15%
lorsqu'on change de logement c'est un 15
% qui se perdent en transaction et donc
ils sont taxés sur 15% de la totalité de
leurs avoir qui sont accumulés sur leur
vie donc la mobilité est très entravée
de par la politique fiscale de par la
politique du PLU et par la politique du
logement qui si quelqu'un a un logement
social dans une zone
à très fort taux de chômage s'il veut
aller ailleurs il a pas de logement
parce qu'il perd son hyper son logement
social donc
si on veut favoriser la mobilité il faut
absolument jouer sur ces trois sur ces
trois dimensions
et je ne pense pas que ça soit
dans les tuyaux
merci d'autres remarques sur les
questions des rapporteurs où on passe à
lisible
je veux bien dire un mot sur
alors nous ce qu'on montre dans à partir
de l'enquête conditions de travail 2019
c'est qu'il y a 29% des salariés qui
travaillent dans une entreprise qui est
certifiée avec une certification qui
porte sur l'environnement ou un label
éthique et pour autant en moyenne c'est
salarié ne trouvent pas plus de sens à
leur travail que les autres donc il
semble que la RSE qui comporte un
certain nombre de limites je rentre pas
dans les détails mais en tout cas ne
constitue pas un signal pertinent pour
les salariés d'une entreprise voilà qui
répondrait à certains standards
notamment relativement
au travail alors on a des témoignages de
jeunes diplômés voilà de grandes écoles
qui par contre attachent une importance
relativement importante à ce qu'offre
les entreprises à leur comportement
vis-à-vis de l'environnement donc il y a
des organisations comme pour un réveil
écologique ou il donne même du matériau
des documents au futur candidats à
l'embauche avec des questions à poser
aux entreprises pour les challenger en
quelque sorte sur ce qu'elles affichent
sur leur site avec des questions très
précises voilà sur leur financeur etc
donc c'est certainement une
problématique qui parle aux jeunes
diplômés mais voilà en moyenne en tout
cas ça n'a pas voilà ça n'a pas beaucoup
d'effets
merci je vais donner la parole à
Florence Blatter
merci il reste très peu de temps
sur la question des jeunes et de dire
tout va bien sur la formation initiale
puisque dans le même temps vous nous
dites que 50% des jeunes trouvent un
emploi en adéquation par défaut ça veut
quand même dire que ça compte pour cent
je trouve pas d'emploi on adéquation
avec leur formation et le taux de
chômage est quand même très élevé chez
les jeunes donc voilà quelle est la
cause de ce taux de chômage et de cette
inadéquation entre le l'emploi trouver
et la formation initiale peut-être
également vous
poser une question vous indiquez
monsieur 7 tout à l'heure que les
entreprises les plus productives étaient
celles qui avaient le plus de
difficultés de recrutement les
entreprises dans la productivité étaient
les plus élevées est-ce que c'est
sectoriel ou est-ce que c'est les
entreprises les plus productives à
l'intérieur d'un même secteur et comment
est-ce que vous vous expliquez cela
j'ai relevé un paradoxe je sais pas si
vous pourrez répondre vous avez indiqué
madame que c'est dans les PME qu'on
trouvait le plus de sens au travail et
en même temps c'est dans les PME où l'on
a le plus de difficultés à recruter donc
comment expliquer ce paradoxe
et peut-être puisqu'il ne reste plus
guère de temps
votre analyse sur notre niveau de
chômage structurel est-ce que c'est
finalement le on s'est habitué à un
chômage conjoncturel élevé ce qui
empêche le chômage structurel de baisser
à votre avis à quel niveau on peut
espérer
voilà
quel niveau de chômage structurel pour
la France et comment faire pour
l'atteindre et pour le réduire
si Florence qui veut commencer peut-être
madame péage du coup
d'adéquation Formation Emploi je pense
il y a beaucoup de travaux au cérec qui
ont documenté cette question et qui
explique que pour des formations
relativement
généraliste voilà les les
jeunes diplômés peuvent trouver au gré
des mobilités des opportunités de leurs
réseaux des emplois qui ne correspondent
pas exactement à la formation qu'ils ont
suivi et c'est d'autant plus vrai que
ils ont suivi des formations longues
avec des compétences qui sont
transférables finalement d'un métier à
l'autre mais encore une fois je pense
que les travaux du sérac sont beaucoup
plus précis pour pour documenter cette
cette question alors par rapport au
paradoxe que vous relevez sur PME
essence du travail alors effectivement
les salariés trouvent en moyenne plus de
sens dans les PME certainement parce
qu'il voit davantage peut-être la
finalité de leur travail les tenants et
les aboutissants peut-être aussi ils ont
davantage d'autonomie ils sont plus plus
polyvalents d'une certaine manière quant
aux difficultés à recruter ce qui est
aussi relevé dans la littérature c'est
la difficulté des PME à formuler leurs
besoins
outre les difficultés dont nous avons
déjà parlé de connaissances finalement
des réseaux
et de d'avoir une personne dédiée pour
justement bien définir le besoin et et
aller à sa recherche il y a un collègue
qui a fondé le concept d'employeurs
habilités c'est-à-dire on regarde
souvent les difficultés de recrutement
du point de vue des caractéristiques des
demandeurs d'emploi mais il faut aussi
regarder les difficultés que peuvent
avoir les employeurs à définir leurs
besoins à cibler les bonnes personnes et
les bons canaux de recrutement en
fonction des postes qu'ils ont à
pourvoir
sur les questions
du rapporteur est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
enzymes oui peut-être juste très
rapidement sur le chômage des jeunes
effectivement élevé mais c'est un
indicateur qu'il faut prendre avec un
peu de précaution parce que le
les comportements d'activité au moment
de l'insertion dans le marché du travail
et ils sont
l'insertion peut prendre un peu de temps
donc et on mesure aussi les jeunes
actifs sont ceux qui sont sortis plus
tôt donc un des difficultés peut-être
d'employabilité plus importante nous on
y préfère aujourd'hui le taux de
l'indicateur qui est les jeunes ni en
emploi ni en formation en anglais connu
sous le la chronique
et là-dessus nous on est plutôt dans une
situation assez bonne par rapport à nos
voisins européens on est à entre 10 et
12% de jeunes sur les 15-29 ans qui
n'ont ni emploi ni formation donc c'est
un taux qui est assez bon et peut-être
juste sur le chômage structurel sur ces
questions là
aujourd'hui on a l'impression un peu au
niveau macroéconomique quand on de
l'ensemble des indicateurs les emplois
vacants des choses comme ça qu'on a
atteint un petit peu le chômage
d'équilibre que
conjoncturelles voilà la conjoncture ne
joue plus sur le taux de chômage
effectivement aujourd'hui si on veut
continuer à faire baisser le taux de
chômage donc comme je dis comme on
montrait et qui atteint un plateau là à
cette ennemi pour cent effectivement
c'est plutôt sur des mesures
structurelles qu'il faudrait qu'il
faudrait fonder donc j'ai pas de de
recettes magiques c'est pas forcément
mon rôle ici mais en tout cas sur le
niveau macroéconomique on a bien
l'impression qu'on atteint l'un un
plancher conjoncturel quoi
[Musique]
sur la l'écart de productivité c'était
toutes choses égales par ailleurs ce 7%
donc effectivement on neutralisant les
faits de l'appartenance sectorielle de
la taille etc 7% plus productive pour
les entreprises qui qui signale des
difficultés de recrutement c'est quand
même pas rien mais encore une fois comme
on demandait aux entreprises dans cette
enquête qu'elle était le nombre de
postes concernés par ces difficultés de
recrutement avec un petit peu de règles
de 3 on voit que ces difficultés de
recrutement plombent sans doute
évidemment en partie la croissance mais
ce qu'on a évalué nous
dans quelle mesure ça plombe le niveau
de la productivité
la performance productive au niveau
global et dans l'industrie on
aboutissait un chiffrage qui nous a
surpris d'ailleurs de 0,15% même sous
des hypothèse assez assez lente alors
sur le taux de chômage structurel je
dirais faut être quand même prudent il y
a quelques années beaucoup de gens
auraient été n'aurait pas parié qu'on
pouvait descendre à 7-300 grosse tension
sur l'économie vous voyez grosse tension
salariale puisque juste avant la crise
covid on connaissait pas des tensions
salariales excessives en France donc ça
c'est un premier premier point un
deuxième point l'indicateur vraiment à
privilégié c'est évidemment celui du
taux d'emploi c'est évidemment celui que
j'emploie et là là on est très mal et on
voit pas pourquoi la France comparée à
d'autres pays qui nous entourent comme
l'Allemagne les Pays-Bas les pays
nordiques scandinaves etc serait voué à
avoir un taux d'emploi bail en
particulier pour les personnes de plus
de plutôt s'entendre parce que là c'est
un des segments actuel c'est un des
segments dans lequel on est
particulièrement bas par rapport à
d'autres pays l'écart a été donné par
Dimitri tout à l'heure c'est quand même
gigantesque on voit pourquoi on serait
voué à ça pourquoi les les individus les
Français enfin les résidents en France
entre 60 et 74 ans aurait moins la
possibilité d'être au travail
physiquement psychologiquement ou autre
que les Néerlandais que peut-être moins
la possibilité de trouver du travail
parce que quand même c'est un parcours
du combattant quand on est senior en
France pour trouver un emploi
ça c'est une mais il y a quand même des
incitations qui ont été largement
soulignées par par Dimitri c'est l'âge
complètement en accord avec lui sur
l'accès aux chômage sur l'accès il y a
quand même des mauvaises incitations qui
existent en France et on pourrait en
faire la liste elles sont elles sont
nombreuses pour pousser en dehors de
l'emploi les populations des seniors
c'est quand même énorme je veux dire
cette liste sera intéressante à cette
liste intéressante à faire on peut
parler des des durées d'indemnisation on
peut parler des des de l'effort de la
recherche d'emploi on peut voir la liste
vous voyez serait considérable
considérable
on est malheureusement obligé de
conclure donc Madame Monsieur Merci
beaucoup de c'était la première table
ronde sur ce sujet donc
elle était très riche déjà d'ouverture
de de questionnement
on a noté un certain nombre de points
qui seront nécessaires à creuser grâce à
vos à vos informations merci beaucoup et
bonne on aura l'occasion peut-être se
retourner vers vous et puis quand vous
aurez quelques temps de regarder notre
questionnaire pour aller un peu plus
profondément dans les choses et enrichir
le travail de nos rapporteurs merci à
tous